foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
fellas NFL bets we love hey it's the
Thursday night football Edition hope you
guys are ready because we asked you in
the app and on Twitter for your locks
tonight Ryan let's pull up Twitter let's
pull up Twitter and see what the people
had to say well I have something else
queued up on Twitter before we go to
that uh if we wanna if if we just want
to roll roll the clip from last week
because I think we were trying to decide
on an anytime touchdown score last week
um and I had it tossed to me that I gave
I gave out a pick I mean I couldn't
remember who so so let's just see this
one then so we put our foot down Trevor
Lawrence how do you type touchdown no no
okay
should we put our foot down Sam is this
it this is it it's not zombies 400. no
no not sodomin well I I don't well I'll
cut off from when I was saying Zona
midnight because he didn't score a
touchdown but I think I brought up
Trevor Lawrence
and I think Trevor Lawrence was the only
person who scored a touchdown
no no comment
congratulations
you know when they when they started the
show Ryan there's a graphic pillow
that's there's a graphic below that said
it was week 17 and you're talking about
week 16. so I just want to set the
president for when I bring up somebody
who's touched on odds are maybe like
plus 300 tonight and you guys laughed me
off the stage that I A plus 600 play
would have hit last week
we do this parlay segment for 20 minutes
and a ton of names and bats are thrown
out there and then if the parlay ends up
losing by one leg you will go back in
there and find one bet that you discuss
when there's 15 others that we discussed
that didn't hit and only bring up that
one you know should we you know who
should be talking [ __ ] right now it
should be Greg because Greg had the Jag
the Jags last week and talked about how
bad Zach Wilson was and you and I were
idiots and we trusted Zach Wilson and we
lost so kudos to Greg Greg Greg should
be talking hey I told you guys I told
you guys Zach Wilson do not believe in
him at all but you know you know how
that goes that you know how that goes
but Ryan
you did call the Trevor Lawrence you did
call the Trevor Lawrence but like Sam
said bro like
hey we discussed so many plays last week
I have access to the same editing tools
that you do Sam your unwillingness to to
out clip me uh is your downfall at the
end of it that's it he started let's
head into tonight's game I think the
Cowboys are the better team yeah yeah
tonight definitely tonight's game
hey Ryan's want to start a clip War so I
guess that's what this show is going to
turn into we're just going to be
bringing a bunch of clips of the
previous show uh to you guys in the
current show and uh just talk about us
being wrong and right I guess that's
what this show is going to become but
welcome to the show welcome to the show
everybody my name is Greg Ivory next to
me is the man the myth the legend I call
them Sam the sharp Richmond you might
call him Sam Richmond he's next to me
and next to him is the guy that connects
the chat to us we like to call him
producer Ryan he likes to call himself
the man of the people but trademark yeah
no he's amen of the people uh but make
sure you guys drop your locks in the
chat we'll be grading your picks at the
end of the show right now we need your
help building a same game parlay for
Thursday Night Football Ryan tell the
people what we need
we need a leg we need many legs well
five we need five legs from you guys
um but we have the Tweet pulled up from
earlier uh asked on Twitter uh for a leg
in the same game parlay jump in the chat
and let us know what you like tonight
and we'll discuss it but let's try and
let's pin a Twitter reply against a chat
comment right now
uh let's see let's see let's see let's
see Dak over 19 and a half completions
he may not even have to throw 19 passes
tonight with how much football this is
gonna be you may not have to do it uh
not oh I like Tony power two plus TDS
I like that one I also like that this
person jumped in here and said no luck
but CD lamb anytime touchdown
just owning the fact that you don't
think it's a lock don't what are we
doing okay
okay I'll give it don't give it uh Zeke
anytime touchdown that's a popular one
tonight uh Zeke 2td oh Malik Davis this
is also uh a popular one
um
B Thompson three plus sacks for Dallas
in the chat
so
how do we want to go about this
gentlemen
well who wants to draw First Blood I
think we should start by just
we don't want to touch any spread in
this parlay right we want to because to
me I feel like from a stretch I mean for
this is my perspective feels completely
unbeatable in my opinion so I'm just
gonna throw that out there yeah yeah I
think there are other ways to to bet
this game in terms of if you think the
Cowboys are gonna beat up on the Titans
also uh before we move over to
DraftKings here adult Schultz anytime
touchdown um
I wasn't going to touch on the anytime
TD Factor because obviously last week's
parlay we felt really good about that we
wanted to throw in an anytime TD to sort
of juice up the juice up the odds and it
was the only leg that didn't hit
um and no one had any suggestions of
what the winning anytime TD bet would be
which would end up being Trevor Lawrence
so my God nobody's there we stay away
from anytime TD The Only Exception this
again is just my takes the only
exception I think would be Zeke because
yeah you should but anyone else like I
don't want to do CD or Gallup or Haskins
I don't want to mess with any of those
to like juice up the parlay it's like
give me the lock and Zeke or I want to
do the player props which we've proved
we've proved last week that we're gurus
at yeah I agree Sam really so let's lock
in Zeke
well I mean everybody in the comments
wants Zeke a lot of those people that
you just read in that Twitter uh
response one is Zeke
that's the anytime touchdown you want to
go for the Cowboys are going to score a
gajillion points tonight and you don't
think they're not the total is four
bajillion yeah the total 40 they're on
the road what does that have to do with
anything the total is 40 because Josh
Dobbs is that quarterback
they're on the road bro it means that
the Cowboys are going to get up big and
they're probably not going to run up
they've no once they get up 14 17 points
so the Cowboys are gonna get a big
how do you get up big
by handing the ball to Zeke
my scoring touchdowns
Anthony uh Marcio jumped in here and
said he likes Cowboys over two and a
half touchdowns I think if we want to do
a lock
let's add that in there we'll go to the
let me shoot you know show me the
numbers you know I I'm an odds guy all
right remember Zeke was minus 195.
I'm not putting in Zeke is like a juicy
cool play I'm putting it in as like Evan
Ingram over two and a half receptions
minus five thousand last week and you're
using that for any time touchdown
why
we could do that no I'm saying I'm
saying that's the only one I'm willing
to consider other than that I don't want
to do anytime TD so I'm going to say I
find ridiculous this is a this is a
school of thought thing that we're that
we're fighting on here I I I really
think that that's I we have why are we
gonna risk what is going to end up being
a lock parlay on like Michael Gallup
plus 225 score touchdown
minus 800 a nice little lock to start
off delay there's no scenario where that
does not hit there's no there's no
scenario where this one doesn't hit Ryan
over two and a half Ryan it's minus 800
Greg what are we doing
it's three touchdowns
we know that they're going to score too
the defense is probably gonna score
tonight that's how many touchdowns are
going to be scored
ask the audience Jordan Grimm said Zeke
is too easy I agree ASM this is the same
juice if Zeke is easy we might as well
take this easy yet the same juice
bagel and locks over two and a half
please with four Z's Darion 85 Ryan do
your Cowboys over 26 and a half total
points again stay tuned I think we
should ask the chat do you want this
parlay to hit or do you want a eight to
one ten to one yeah yeah same fine with
either if we want to go 10-1 parlay and
be like hey you know we're just gonna go
for it I'm fine with that but if the
chat wants us to win then I think we
need to start looking at over one and a
half touchdowns I love your reasoning
brother I love that reasoning Sam
because we're trying to win we're I mean
as as pretty as these parlay tickets
that are like 12 to 1 14. you remember
last week Ryan at the end of the show
when we were when Greg was going through
the parlay and he was rushing off the
legs and I said lock over everything and
then we got to Ichi and touchdown and I
was like eh we might that might not hit
I want every one of these legs to me for
me to be able to say lock lock I agree
this show one and a half touchdown 15
years off my life one and a half
touchdowns
oh it's so juicy overts
Dante Rotella says over two and a half
touchdown seems too easy let's remember
it's the cat
let's remember let's just slot in one
and a half and then we'll we'll after
we've crafted you know rolling one leg
again yeah yeah okay all right there it
is this is I just like I literally last
week after I we I don't understand why
you think because it's plus 200 means
it's like it's more likely to hit in
terms of the odds that doesn't mean it's
going to hit we might as well we might
as well try and make legitimate
cashola off of this rather than build a
five-leg parlay that's minus 185. right
and again you're throwing a bunch of big
words at me yeah you're gonna take
I mean your strategy hasn't led us to
the promised land in the last like three
years everyone you know B worm one says
we want to win we all want the money win
exactly we want to win
whatever right I love you and I know
your record on this show is is really
good pristine according according to you
it's really good five to two five and
two five and two
but brother we're trying to win we're
we're trying to win here and your
strategy of getting rich
I mean it just hasn't led us to pay dirt
all right so we've locked we've locked
that in temporary now a lot of people
are throwing out sacks in the comments
yeah I was gonna say B Thompson three
sacks uh well we're the team sacks this
is it this is
team sacks is interesting but so is oh
we don't have the team sacks hey I like
that Michael Parsons one sec he he's
been slumping I like it too oh yeah I
don't hate that touch it why not
mine I mean
this is Juicy man minus 160. talk Dirty
to Me Jesus
[Laughter]
uh
yeah it says we have to go to another
section for team sacks okay I will keep
moving
um but let's see
I I'm curious the uh chats take on Micah
Parson sex yeah you guys give us thumbs
up thumbs down to Michael Parson and get
one sack tonight I think he's due
he was like the defensive player of the
year he had it booked but then uh you
know that boy from San Francisco yeah
you know that's
pushing propaganda tonight huh Greg she
took over I I don't think that's I don't
think that's the the case here Sam
yeah I think big unlock slide to us
um it's usually in that section
um
all right let's see what else of the
chat has
someone threw out Titans to lose a
fumble
k-pak Cowboys fan picking a Cowboys over
shocker it's the practice squad Titans
a lot of CD love I will say that and I
don't want to touch touchdown but I'm
willing to entertain more attainable CD
props I'm seeing lamb over 54 and a half
yards
it seems like oh oh Ryan you might lock
this one you might like this one Dalton
Schultz over 39 in the half now I'm not
I'm not big on The Yards if somebody
were to if somebody were in a
hypothetical sense to jump in here and
say Dalton Schultz anytime touchdown uh
I would entertain it Sam wooden Sam
wouldn't entertain it not for one second
but I would
yeah CD lamb over 54 and a half
receiving yards minus 235 in in all
honesty
like oh [ __ ] did you see what I just saw
I did Barbarian yes he said yes yes I
love that yes yes that is a good one
okay
our minds both went to the same place
yeah let's go there okay Dairy for those
who didn't see it darian85 said Titans
under 17 and a half total points oh my I
I love this yes yeah that's so good
that's so good where are we at
uh here we go under seven only minus
340. that's pretty good oh plus sign
that's pretty good wow
okay I like this should add Zeke to
score
uh Ritter jumped in here and said I feel
like yards is safer than receptions for
CD
I feel like yeah that's true
I'm kind of scared of the Micah
parsonsack can I just say that
are you really
yeah you know he hasn't had he's had one
sack in his last four games and we're
gonna lay minus 235 that he's gonna get
one that's why he's due
uh the only thing I'm concerned about
with it is like the Titans could very
well just
run the Navy offense tonight and not
throw it once
you know that's true yeah I mean Dobbs
was signed off yeah
and go back to CD
that's my suggestion then I'll clip out
later
uh we're being dared to take any time
touchdown
um I think yeah I think we should ask
the chat thumbs up thumbs down if we
should take Zeke anytime TV ah don't put
the words in the chat's mouth
nobody specifically right now in this
current state or this current iteration
of the chat and this current iteration
of the chat is saying Zeke to score a
touchdown Zeke anytime versus Cowboys
it's like the fifth chat it's like the
fifth comment from the top from Jared
it's that I'm I I'm not people like
people like the CD over
uh CD over receiving yards
54 and a half
do you guys like the CD over
we need to be honest
I have fantasy obligations this week I
mean it's just about going up against
going up against CD and deck so I'm okay
his last two games 120 yards 126 yards
33 yards 71 yards 106. to me that's
that's a hit poverty
Titans have a poverty pass defense it's
worth it it's worth a Sprinkle
uh I mean it was the same odds as the
Parsons sack so it's like we're we're
back at the same I feel like this is a
better chance of hitting though he's hit
this in front of his last five games
Parsons has sacked twice in his last
five games That's Good Sam and you know
what else has a good chance of hitting
Zeke to score a touchdown I think he's
scored in his last like what eight seven
games all right Greg I think I think you
you need to we need to ask the chat just
for the thumbs up thumbs down on on Zeke
hey I don't think so we said we were
gonna leave this to last to see where
we're at because Ritter jumped in here
and goes the parlay is minus 205 right
now what is happening yeah I don't know
what's happening I've lost control and
I'm the one who's on DraftKings
Ryan are you afraid to let the chat pick
because I mean half of this is like your
propaganda majority of it it's
influenced by your propaganda but when
we want to ask the chat you're like
anti-chat when the show is about the
chat I'm not anti-chat most of these
plays currently the the plays that are
in here are over one and a half Cowboys
touchdowns what the chat wanted was two
and a half touchdowns I the only my only
beef right now is that you guys you see
a check comment and you tease it down
let's see what the let's see what the
parlay would pay out if we change the
two and a half look at all look at all
the Z it's not gonna be that much right
why aren't you not listening to it what
be worm be worm says Ryan or why aren't
you not listening to us uh everyone here
is on Zeke uh
let's just see what it looks like now go
throw in Zeke let's just we're we're
trying to look at the numbers
they're calling you anti-chat Brian
this is unbelievable I'm gonna lose my
title as being a man as being the man of
the people it's not a good look
they're calling you this is pretty good
this is pretty good not Sam this is
Lockheed I'm not gonna lie
I like it
we need one more though we need one more
alive yeah we need to get this into the
400 range I personally I would be a fan
of Michael Gallup
um no no no no no no no we can't do that
no let's go get like a Lockheed lock
like Dak to throw over 200 yards yeah
something like Greg I like what you're
thinking
I just wanted to give that some some
audio padding there so when I clip it
out it's a cleaning it's a clean cut I
know exactly what you're doing there
that's hilarious
uh
yeah let's see what did you see that
yeah yeah 194 and a half
so you guys you guys got this pick from
the chat
yeah
yeah
but what Chad is doing right now he's
commenting on how they want Zeke so
you're you're saying that it works
against you Zeke is in there
I know they're they're still you know uh
773-1985 Gallup TD thank you uh yeah
[Laughter]
a bog Dak over 19 completions we'll do
the 200 yards passing we'll do where we
need to get to the alternate
uh
yeah okay so so do the 194 and a half
though yeah yeah
right I guess they have the same exact
same thing yeah I didn't know if it
would be a push on 195 but I worked out
in my head in a half second so yeah
gotcha uh
crazy uh the comments are crazy
uh Sam wants to get in the 400 range I
mean Sam we can go up to 220. uh Josh
Dobbs interceptions
he's gonna throw it four times
guys when you guys walk in here do you
do you plan on being difficult or is
this just is this a spur of the moment
kind of deal for you I'm just trying to
win yeah that's it also we already have
we so wait hold on hold on because it's
supposed to be a five like parlay and we
already have five legs and look at where
we're at so we need to figure it out
but wait if Sam goes through it and says
lock and it wins like does it matter
that it's 370. it does how about this
how about we ask that as a man of the
people as the man of the people I would
like to ask the chat are we okay with
this parlay as it is currently five legs
plus 370. are we okay
if you have a thumbs down add your own
commentary please sorry seven seven
seven seven three one nine eight five
says I'm still shocked as Ryan thinking
he is the man of the people good taste
that's a great thing yeah there's a lot
of comments being thrown around I just
want a thumbs up if you like the parlay
thumbs down if you want us to change
something
that's it we're putting in the we're
putting in the people's hands
darian85 says Josh Dobbs I know what
you're asking Sam I'm waiting for those
to come in but he says Josh Dobbs under
passing yards
the bagel and locks Michael Gallup TD
has longer odds than this parlay
no let's get rich trust in Ryan
I need the I need my arm right that's
your that's your Twitter fingers
it's it seems pretty split it seems
split it's like 50 50. that's your
burner Ryan
uh we got some thumbs down Dante Rotella
thumbs down Ritter five thumbs down
Jordan Grimm thumbs down B fan flipped
us off five times uh R Smith thumbs down
so somebody says that I gotta go that
gotta go uh what about Zeke gotta go
what about if we gotta go Zeke and we
and we add in Dalton you know what Ryan
just for the content I'm willing to let
you take out Zeke and put in something
if the chat agrees with you I don't know
if I need Greg sign off I'm getting am I
getting permission if Greg is with this
and the chat agrees to you you can take
out Zeke and put it in anytime TD parl
it and we can ride with that and then we
can all roast you and Zeke scores and
Noah Brown drops a touchdown
uh Clee light the beam uh my Sacramento
people are back in here uh go ahead Ryan
all right if
it's your show don't say that uh
okay
see look at him now that now that he
actually has the pressure on him and the
decision to make not so confident now
not what I said
um
I just want to see where this Nets us
I'm I'm debating between Dalton Schultz
and
Michael Gallup how about this I'm going
to ask the chat Dalton Schultz or
Michael Gallup in this parlay or neither
and just go we will sacrifice Ryan was a
comment that was just dropping yeah you
guys right Schultz or Zeke yes there you
go a reminder if we add Zeke it's plus
370. we know what those odds look like
not to sway the decision at all I would
never do that
I would never do that trying to win
uh B Thompson Dak at four plus 75
anytime touchdown is juicy
Raider Austin Hooper anytime touchdown
I'm not interested in putting a Titan
anytime touchdown when we also have
their team total under that have boy 99
said change Zeke anytime touchdown to
first half TD
okay what if we do that
anytime touchdown Score first half there
in the mid
oh baby
Plus 575.
that's see looking all right look we got
we got to we have some takes in here
I like this I see Gallop I see Zeke Zeke
Zeke Zeke Zeke I see one Schultz I see
another Schultz Gallop well how about
this uh you know we should do it no it's
actually it was a good take someone said
Cowboys minus six and a half is a lock
and I do think that is a lock
uh you've started the show saying no
spreads but not minus 14. well I thought
that was yeah that was implied that we
weren't going to take minus 14.
people are liking the parlay now there's
a lot of all right I feel like this is
it this we've never gotten this much
love there yeah that's not true I like
that thumbs up there it is this is it
it's over there it is
there it is Ryan
you to be a man of the people you need
to be a man of the people and you need
to right
no it's not that it's you guys push the
chat in a direction where it's like a
it's a yes or a no kind of deal and I
need the I there were Dalton Schultz
takes there were Michael Gallup takes
and we just completely and
everyone said yes I love this and it's
also 5 26. Eastern Time
all right if we like this
let's do it all right so let's let's go
over it it's yeah we're locking it in
yeah we're
we're locking it in okay wait look
before we lock it in let's toss in a
little Cowboys minus six and a half
let's just see what it looks like on top
of this we might be able to push this in
700 800 range with another
lock
no it didn't do anything no we're
checking that out we're taking that out
oh you guys scared me to do anything
yeah no no no no no no no no no no no no
okay all right all right all right all
right this is where we're netting out
this is it this is it is it we're good
we're good okay
under 17 and a half team total points
for the Tennessee Titans over 54 and a
half receiving yards for cd-lam over two
and a half total touchdowns for the
Cowboys
195 plus passing yards for Dak Prescott
and then and anytime TouchDown for Zeke
in the first half
five legs for Plus 575.
let's go
I love it
I like it right yeah I like it
I like it we're riding all right make
sure you guys tell us make sure you guys
tell us on DraftKings hey guys it's
Thursday night so we have to ask Will
there be an offensive score on the first
drive get in the comments and let us
know thumbs up if there is going to be a
score thumbs down if there is not Ryan
Sam out to start off with you guys
before we hop into the chat
you guys think that there's going to be
a a score
on the first drive tonight this one is
tough because it really does come down
to who gets the ball first because the
Titans get the ball first it is a
guaranteed no and if the Cowboys get the
ball first it's a very likely yes so I
would still I would lean no because
there is no chance to Titans score on
their first drive with Josh Dobbs
um but it feels but you know it's risky
because you have to cop always get the
ball you might be toast
Ryan before you go to the chat yeah
what's what's your what's your verdict
on the no Score first drive uh I'm
trying to look at the stats for how many
coin tosses the Cowboys have won this
year they've won 11. so who are our
captains
uh who makes the coin toss call
I think yeah they're on the road so it
would be the Cowboys I think it's I
think it's Micah Parsons and I think
it's Parsons DAC and or no Demarcus
Lawrence and deck I believe that's it uh
so I'll trust them they've won 11 times
this year that would that's tied for
third so I'm gonna say yes based on the
coin toss now I like it I like it March
down the field and score right Ryan's
rocking with the yes Sam's rocking with
the yes uh no wait Sam what was your
what was your verdict I'm taking the
notes rock with the no I'm sorry I'm
whatever size you're on remember to get
on DraftKings and take advantage of that
profit boost but right now right now
we're saving the best for last
I purposely went out of order because I
wanted to save the best for last and
right now it's time for our Best Bets
and uh here's the deal this week here's
the deal
Sam and I we we don't have anything we
love so we're letting right Ryan tonight
it's your night it is your night what
are you looking at tonight yeah this is
the Ryan show this is this is all
designed around Ryan put the chef's hat
on me it's time to cook
I love love love love let me see if I
can go if I go just show it and we'll
I'll display it at the same time as I
say it
Cowboys
team total points tonight is at 26 and a
half the Cowboys this is no hyperbole
are going to score a gajillion points
tonight on the Tennessee Titans this is
a preseason game for the Titans they're
starting their practice squad the
Cowboys since Dak has returned from
injury have scored no less than 24
points in every game that he has played
this is I am Mr I am I am the man of the
people but I am also Mr five and two on
his Best Bets on this show and after
today after tonight we will be six and
two uh this is going to smack this is
one of the easier ones I don't know how
you guys looked at this game and said
you didn't love something because I
looked at this and I fell in love I this
was the first time I I ever said wow I I
think I'm in love I when I saw this team
total over
well offline uh but how are the Cowboys
are not going to score 27 points on the
Tennessee how how is that gonna happen
the only chance I mean I agree with you
the only chances if they cough the dogs
late
or if a meteor hits Earth
if a meteor hits Earth yeah probably
probably the latter is the only thing
that can stop I don't think I like I I
just can't see them in what world are
they calling the dogs off early before
they get to 27. they're like 21-3 in the
fourth quarter against Josh Dobbs who's
just handing it off so they get to week
18. I just I can't see them only scoring
21 points by like but that by the time
they get to the fourth quarter I am
assuming
65 to 75 points will already be scored
by the Cowboys by the time they get
there all right well I hope I hope
you're clipping this out in celebration
we're going to say well we're we're
going to see Ryan
we're gonna see ah but that's it man
that's that's it man I I I'm ready to go
win some bets I don't know about you
guys hopefully you guys in the chat is
ready to go win uh Ryan
you want to give him a little recap
before we get up out of here yes sir so
our five leg same game parlay is under
17 and a half team total points for the
Tennessee Titans over 54 and a half
receiving yards for CD lamb over two and
a half total touchdowns for the Dallas
Cowboys
195 plus passing yards for Dak Prescott
and then in any time first half
TouchDown for Zeke
five legs it's a plus 575.
it's a lot there it is it's a lot oh
right part of the lot there it is
the team total over is more of a lock
but this will also hit
Ryan caught it a lock he likes his team
total over make sure you guys tell us on
DraftKings my name
is Greg Ivory next to me is Sam the man
the myth the legend Richmond and next to
him is a guy we like to call producer
Ryan around these parts uh we we about
to go win some money so we about here
peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]